no chemo no radiation just an injection
to kill off mass tumor cancer cells the
most common type of cancer that we see
in dogs well as heather mills reports
the newer treatment is making it much
easier for pet owners
we call them man's best friend for a
reason they provide so much comfort and
love so when your pet is sick we want
the best treatment and this new option
not only appears to be effective but
also relatively easy on fido
meet rella part of the family ever since
bree barlow adopted her six years ago
she goes to school with me to college
and everything and i do anything to help
her quality of life and keep her with us
longer a life bond tested with a
terminal diagnosis
rela formed a lump on her back leg a
trip to the vet revealed that lump was
cancer a mast cell tumor this tumor when
it is on a limb
cannot be resected
the only way to get the wide resection
is to take the leg the tumor was getting
bigger and bigger which is why we
brought her in and were worried about it
but
it wasn't affecting her enough that i
was willing to amputate the leg rella
was a candidate for the new drug stealth
fonta the medicine is injected into the
masked cell tumor breaking down cancer
cells by starving their blood supply dr
mark epstein served on the drugs
advisory board i knew very well how it
worked and i knew very well what my
expectations were the expectation is for
the tumor to go away in a matter of
weeks leaving behind a hole where
healthy tissue can form
each case of course is unique but varela
two injections proved successful and
today she's cancer-free it's saved her
life and stopped the cancer from
spreading so i would definitely
recommend it side effects are minimal
mostly the healing process now as for
cost less than other options at under a
thousand dollars and it is offered here
in the valley heather mills live local
now